אנחנו חושבים שמחשבים קוונטיים יאפשרו לנו לפתור בעיות מסוימות מהר יותר ממה שאנחנו יכולים עם מחשבים קלאסיים לבד. אבל
להבין איך זה עובד זה עניין עדין. היום ב-Qiskit בכיתה, ננסה לחשוף את מקור העוצמה של
מחשוב קוונטי על ידי מבט באחד מהאלגוריתמים הראשונים
ממש. ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit בכיתה. בסדרה הזו נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לחקור כמה מושגים בסיסיים
שנלמדים בדרך כלל בקורסים הקשורים למחשוב קוונטי. כל סרטון מלווה במודול אינטראקטיבי
שמקושר בתיאור למטה. אז תבדקו את זה. אם שמעתם קצת על מחשבים קוונטיים, כנראה
שמעתם שהם יכולים להשתמש בתופעות קוונטיות כמו סופרפוזיציה, שזירה והתאבכות כדי לפתור
בעיות בדרכים שמחשבים קלאסיים לא יכולים. אבל איך בדיוק התכונות האלה עוזרות? ב-1985, David Deutsch היה
הראשון שהראה איך זה יכול לקרות. הוא המציא את מה שנקרא היום האלגוריתם של Deutsch שיכול לפתור
בעיה בצורה יעילה יותר מאשר אלגוריתם קלאסי. היום נסתכל על האלגוריתם של Deutsch
והרחבה מאוחרת יותר שנקראת האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa ונבחן איך ההיבטים הקוונטיים הייחודיים של ה-qubit-ים
יכולים לשמש לטובת המחשב הקוונטי. אחר כך נריץ את האלגוריתמים האלה על מחשב קוונטי אמיתי עם Qiskit.
יש אלגוריתמים קוונטיים נוספים שגם מראים יתרון תיאורטי על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים ידועים. ולא כולם עובדים
עם אותם עקרונות כמו אלה שנראה היום. אז מה שנלמד היום לא מסביר באופן כללי איך מחשב קוונטי
עובד, אבל זה כן עוזר לנו להתחיל לראות איך עקרונות מכניקת הקוונטים יכולים להשתלב כדי
ליצור מחשב קוונטי חזק. לפני שנצלול לאלגוריתם של Deutsch, בואו קודם נחשוב איך מחשבים קוונטיים
שונים ממחשבים קלאסיים ואיך זה יכול לתת לנו יתרון בפתרון בעיות
מסוימות. הבדל אחד הוא שהביטים הקוונטיים שנקראים qubit-ים יכולים להיות במצבי סופרפוזיציה. במקום להיות
מוגבלים למצב אפס או למצב אחד כמו ביט קלאסי, qubit
יכול להיות במצב סופרפוזיציה של גם אפס וגם אחד. אנחנו כותבים את המצב הזה
ככה, כאשר a ו-b הם מספרים מרוכבים שהריבועים שלהם מסתכמים לאחד, וככל שיש יותר
qubit-ים, הפער הזה גדל יותר. שני ביטים עדיין יכולים להיות רק באחד מארבעת
המצבים האפשריים האלה. 0 0 1 1 0 או 1
1. שני qubit-ים יכולים להיות בסופרפוזיציה של כל ארבעת המצבים המותרים קלאסית, שזה
נכתב ככה. באופן כללי, מערכת קלאסית של n ביטים יכולה להיות רק באחד מ-2 בחזקת n
צירופים אפשריים של אפסים ואחדות. מערכת קוונטית של n qubit-ים יכולה להיות בסופרפוזיציה של כל 2 בחזקת n מהמצבים
האלה. הסקילינג הוא אקספוננציאלי. אז גם אם היו לנו רק 10 qubit-ים, הם
היו יכולים להיות במצב סופרפוזיציה של 2 בחזקת 10, שזה 1,024 צירופים אפשריים של אפסים
ואחדות. הגידול האקספוננציאלי של מרחב המצבים של qubit-ים נקרא הקבלה קוונטית
ואחראי בחלקו ליתרון של מחשבים קוונטיים על מחשבים קלאסיים. אבל מחשב קוונטי
הוא לא סתם מעבד מקבילי ענק. רק בגלל שה-qubit-ים במחשב קוונטי יכולים להיות
בסופרפוזיציה של מספר אקספוננציאלי של מצבים, זה לא אומר שיש לנו גישה לכל המידע בכל אחד מהמצבים
האלה. מכיוון שמדידה מקריסה את המערכת למצב אחד או אחר, בואו
נראה איך זה מתבטא בבעיה פשוטה. נגיד שיש מכונה כלשהי
שאפשר להזין לה ביט בודד. אז היא תפעיל פונקציה כלשהי על הביט ותפלוט ביט בודד אחר. המכונה
נמצאת בתוך קופסה שחורה שאין לנו גישה אליה. כל מה שיש לנו גישה אליו זה הביט
שאנחנו מזינים x והביט שהקופסה פולטת f
של x. אנחנו רוצים להבין מהי הפונקציה f שהמכונה מפעילה.
יש ארבע פונקציות אפשריות שלוקחות ביט בודד לביט בודד אחר.
אז כדי לגלות מה הפונקציה, אנחנו יכולים פשוט להזין אפס ולראות אם היא פולטת אפס או אחד. אחר כך להזין
אחד ולעשות את אותו הדבר. כל אחד משני הצעדים האלה נקרא שאילתה. זוהי
דרך אחת להשוות אלגוריתמים קלאסיים וקוונטיים דרך מה שנקרא מודל השאילתות, שבו אנחנו משווים את מספר
השאילתות שכל אחד מהאלגוריתמים צריך לבצע לקופסה השחורה כדי לפתור את הבעיה. אז במקרה הזה,
השיטה הקלאסית שלנו הייתה צריכה לשאול את הקופסה פעמיים כדי ללמוד את הפונקציה. בואו נראה אם נוכל לעשות את זה טוב יותר אם יש לנו מחשב קוונטי
ששואל את הקופסה השחורה. במקום להזין קודם אפס ואז אחד,
המחשב הקוונטי יכול להזין לקופסה qubit שנמצא בסופרפוזיציה של אפס
ואחד. אז בעצם, אנחנו מזינים לקופסה את שני הקלטים בשאילתה אחת. אז
האם זה אומר שאנחנו יכולים ללמוד את הפונקציה עם שאילתה אחת בלבד?
לצערנו, זה לא המקרה. אנחנו רואים למה הרעיון הזה נכשל כשבודקים אותו על מחשב קוונטי. ניצור
circuit עם שני qubit-ים. qubit אפס שמיוצג כאן על ידי הקו העליון יהיה מצב הקלט X שלנו שאנחנו מזינים
לקופסה השחורה שמוצגת כאן על ידי ה-gate הבורדו שמסומן UF. ה-gate UF
מתוכנן לקחת את qubit אפס כמצב הקלט X ואז להפעיל טרנספורמציה על qubit אחד שלוקחת
את המצב אפס למצב f של x. אז כל עוד qubit 1 התחיל במצב
אפס, הפלט הוא x על qubit 0 ו-f של x על qubit 1. אז כדי למצוא f של x עבור
גם x=0 וגם x=1 בו-זמנית אנחנו יכולים לנסות לשים את qubit 0 בסופרפוזיציה של 0 ו-1 לפני
שאנחנו מזינים אותו לקופסה השחורה. זה נעשה עם gate ה-Hadamard האדום הזה שמשנה את מצב האפס ל-1 חלקי שורש 2
כפול 0 + 1. אז אחרי ה-gate של הקופסה השחורה, עכשיו אמורה להיות לנו סופרפוזיציה של גם
f של 0 וגם f של 1 על qubit 1. כשאנחנו מודדים את שני ה-qubit-ים, אנחנו מקווים
לענות על השאלה, איזו פונקציה נמצאת בתוך הקופסה השחורה. בואו נשתמש ב-sampler primitive של Qiskit כדי להריץ את
ה-circuit ולהחזיר את התוצאה. אנחנו יכולים לבחור את מספר הפעמים שה-circuit רץ שנקרא דגימות על ידי שינוי
הפרמטר הזה שנקרא shots כאן.
זה שווה ערך למספר השאילתות שאנחנו עושים לקופסה השחורה. בואו נראה אם שאילתה אחת בלבד
תספיק. הנה התוצאה. מדדנו את qubit 0 כאפס. אז זה היה
ערך הקלט x ואת qubit 1 כאחד, שזה היה ערך הפלט f של x. אז עכשיו אנחנו
יודעים ש-f של 0 שווה 1. אבל מה עם f של 1? פה הבעיה. ברגע
שמדדנו את המצב, הסופרפוזיציות קרסו ורק הצלחנו למדוד חלק אחד של הפונקציה עם
שאילתה אחת. זה לא אומר לנו את כל מה שאנחנו צריכים לדעת כדי לקבוע איזו פונקציה זו. היינו צריכים
שאילתה שנייה לקופסה בשביל זה. אז למרות שעקרון ההקבלה הקוונטית מאפשר לנו בו-זמנית
לגרום לקופסה השחורה לחשב f של 0 ו-f של 1, אין לנו גישה לשתי
התשובות. הקבלה קוונטית לבד לא מספיקה. האלגוריתם של Deutsch
מראה איך אפשר להשתמש בהקבלה קוונטית קצת אחרת כדי ללמוד על הפונקציה שבתוך הקופסה השחורה. לא
נוכל ללמוד בדיוק מה הפונקציה, אבל כן נוכל ללמוד משהו חדש עליה עם
שאילתה אחת שלא יכולנו עם מחשב קלאסי. בואו נתחיל בהסתכלות על טבלה של ארבע הפונקציות האפשריות
שלוקחות ביט בודד לביט בודד אחר. כאן אתם יכולים לראות ששתיים מהפונקציות f_sub_1 ו-f_sub_4 תמיד
מחזירות ערך יחיד ללא קשר למצב הקלט. אנחנו קוראים לשתי הפונקציות האלה
קבועות. f_sub_2 ו-f_sub_3 יחזירו אפס או אחד בהתאם
למצב של x. אנחנו קוראים לשתי הפונקציות האלה מאוזנות. האלגוריתם של Deutsch
קובע אם הפונקציה קבועה או מאוזנת על ידי כמה התאמות חכמות ל-circuit שהשתמשנו בו
קודם. הנה ה-circuit. הוא מתחיל בהכנת qubit 0 למצב 1 חלקי שורש
2 כפול 0 + 1 עם Hadamard כמו קודם ו-qubit 1 למצב 1 חלקי שורש 2 כפול 0 מינוס 1
עם gate NOT ואחריו Hadamard.
אז המצב המלא בנקודה הזו הוא כאשר זה המצב של qubit 0
וזה המצב של qubit 1. הכנת qubit אחד בצורה כזו במקום פשוט
להשאיר אותו במצב אפס מאפשרת לאלגוריתם להשתמש בהקבלה קוונטית בשילוב עם התאבכות כדי ללמוד
על פונקציית הקופסה השחורה. בואו נראה איך כשה-qubit-ים מוזנים ל-UF, ה-gate של הקופסה השחורה, כמה דברים יכולים
לקרות. אם הפונקציה קבועה, אז הקופסה השחורה תבצע פעולה כלשהי על qubit אחד לבד ללא קשר
למצב של אפס. במקרה הזה, מכיוון ש-UF לא נוגע ב-qubit אפס או
מתעניין במצב שלו בכלל, אז ה-Hadamard השני כאן פשוט מבטל את מה
שה-Hadamard הראשון עשה. ונמדוד את ה-qubit במצב אפס. בואו נסתכל על הפונקציה המאוזנת f_sub_2 כדוגמה כדי לראות
מה uf עושה למצב במקרה הזה. כש-x הוא אפס, f של x הוא אפס וכש-x
הוא 1, f של x הוא 1. תזכרו מה אמרתי לכם על ה-uf gate. הוא לוקח את qubit 0
כמצב הקלט x שלנו ומוציא f של x על qubit 1. בהנחה ש-qubit 1
התחיל במצב אפס. אז עבור הפונקציה הזו מה ש-UF עושה ל-qubit 1 תלוי
ב-qubit 0. אם 0 הוא אפס אז qubit 1 יישאר במצב אפס כדי לקבל f
של x שווה 0. אם qubit 0 הוא 1, הקופסה השחורה תפעיל gate NOT על qubit 1 ותשים
אותו במצב אחד. אז נקבל f של 1 שווה 1. זה בדיוק מה ש-gate CNOT עושה.
gate CNOT לוקח שני qubit-ים, qubit בקרה ו-qubit מטרה, והופך את
המצב של qubit המטרה אם qubit הבקרה במצב אחד. אבל הוא לא עושה כלום ל-qubit המטרה אם qubit
הבקרה במצב אפס. אז UF עבור F2 הוא פשוט CNOT על Q0 ו-Q1. ה-gate
CNOT לא יעשה כלום לאיבר הראשון כי qubit הבקרה במצב אפס. אבל באיבר השני, האפס
הזה הופך לאחד והאחד הזה הופך לאפס. ואם נוציא סימן מינוס כגורם משותף, נראה שהמצב של qubit 1
לא השתנה. אבל האיבר הזה קיבל סימן מינוס. אז המצב של qubit 0
הוא זה שבעצם השתנה. הוא עבר מלהיות 0 + 1 להיות 0 מינוס
אחד. כשאנחנו מפעילים את ה-Hadamard האחרון על qubit 0, זה משנה אותו למצב 1. אז אם הפונקציה בקופסה השחורה
היא f_sub_2, נמדוד אחד במקום אפס. מסתבר שה-gate UF עבור הפונקציה המאוזנת השנייה f3 הוא אותו
gate CNOT ואחריו NOT על qubit 1. ה-gate NOT האחרון לא משפיע על qubit אפס. אז כשהפונקציה
מאוזנת, נמדוד את qubit 0 במצב אחד בסוף ה-circuit. עכשיו אם לא עקבתם אחרי כל
הדברים האלה, זה בסדר. אני מציע שתעברו על זה לבד כדי לראות איך זה עובד. הנקודה העיקרית כאן היא מה
שקרה כשהפעלנו את ה-CNOT עבור שתי הפונקציות המאוזנות. qubit 0 שימש רק כ-qubit בקרה כדי לשנות
את המצב של qubit 1. אינטואיטיבית, אתם עלולים לחשוב ש-qubit 0 יישאר ללא שינוי. ובכל זאת, איכשהו
הפעולות שלנו על qubit אחד בעצם שינו את המצב של qubit אפס על ידי שינוי הפאזה היחסית בין שני החלקים של
הסופרפוזיציה שלו. התופעה הזו ידועה כמנגנון ה-phase kickback והיא
מאוד לא אינטואיטיבית כמו הרבה תופעות קוונטיות. בצורה מסוימת, אפשר לחשוב על מנגנון ה-phase kickback
כמו חתירה בסירה. הפעולה של דחיפת מים אחורה בעצם דוחפת אותך קדימה. בדיוק כמו שהפעולות על
qubit 1 בעצם משנות את qubit אפס. עכשיו אנחנו יכולים להריץ את האלגוריתם של Deutsch על
Qiskit. כאן אנחנו יכולים לבחור איזו פונקציה לשים בתוך הקופסה השחורה ובחרנו ב-F3. הנה
דיאגרמת ה-circuit של האלגוריתם ואנחנו יכולים להריץ אותו כמו קודם עם sampler primitive. נקבע את מספר
הדגימות לאחד בלבד ונראה מה אנחנו מודדים. במקרה הזה, מדדנו אחד.
אז אנחנו יודעים שהפונקציה הייתה מאוזנת, שזה אכן מה שציפינו כי הקופסה השחורה הכילה את הפונקציה f3. אז עם שאילתה
אחת בלבד, הצלחנו להבדיל בין שתי הקבוצות האלה של פונקציות.
לאלגוריתם קלאסי היה לוקח שתי שאילתות לקבוע את זה. זה מראה יתרון צנוע של מחשוב קוונטי
על מחשוב קלאסי לבד, אבל זה לא כל כך מרשים. רק אחד לעומת שניים. אבל האלגוריתם של Deutsch
עדיין חשוב מאוד להיסטוריה של מחשוב קוונטי כי הוא סיפק את הניצוץ שגרם לאחרים
לחשוב על אלגוריתמים קוונטיים גדולים ומתוחכמים יותר.
זה כולל הרחבה מרובת qubit-ים של האלגוריתם של Deutsch שמדגימה יתרון קוונטי הרבה יותר מרשים.
זה נקרא האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa. הוא פותר בעיה דומה, אבל במקרה הזה, פונקציית הקופסה השחורה
שאנחנו רוצים ללמוד עליה מקבלת n ביטים כקלט ומוציאה ביט בודד.
כמו קודם, מובטח לנו שהפונקציה היא או קבועה, כלומר ביט הפלט תמיד אחד או תמיד אפס,
ללא קשר למחרוזת ביטים של הקלט, או מאוזנת, כלומר הפלט הוא אפס עבור
חצי ממחרוזות הקלט ואחד עבור החצי השני. כמובן שיש
פונקציות אחרות שלוקחות n ביטים לביט בודד שהן לא קבועות ולא מאוזנות. אבל בבעיה הזו, מובטח
לנו שאף אחת מהפונקציות האלה לא נמצאת בקופסה השחורה. זו שבקופסה מובטחת להיות או קבועה
או מאוזנת. ה-circuit של Deutsch-Jozsa נראה דומה לאלגוריתם של Deutsch, אבל עם יותר qubit-ים. כאן יש לנו
מימוש של האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa כדי ללמוד על פונקציה של שלושה ביטים. הפעם יש לנו שלושה qubit-ים
למצב הקלט במקום רק אחד. ואז יש לנו את ה-qubit האחרון הזה למצב הפלט. כמו קודם, שוב
אנחנו מכינים את כל qubit-י הקלט להיות במצב 0 + אחד ואת qubit הפלט
להיות במצב 0 מינוס אחד. אז למרות שהמתמטיקה קצת יותר מסובכת לעקוב, העיקרון
נשאר אותו דבר. אם הפונקציה קבועה, היא לא תהיה תלויה בשלושת ה-qubit-ים העליונים בכלל. אז המצבים שלהם
ישתנו בחזרה לאפס אחרי ה-Hadamard-ים השניים והמדידה שלנו תניב מחרוזת של שלושה ביטים שכולם
אפסים. אבל אם הפונקציה מאוזנת אז כשנמדוד את ה-qubit-ים אחרי ה-Hadamard-ים, מנגנון ה-phase kickback
יגרום לאחד או יותר מהביטים האלה להיות אחד. זה אולי לא כל כך קל לראות הפעם אבל אם תעבדו
דרך כל שלב בעצמכם תראו מהר שזה חייב להיות המקרה. דרך אחת לבדוק את זה היא לנסות לחשב את
ההסתברות למדוד אפסים בלבד עם פונקציה מאוזנת. אתם אמורים לקבל הסתברות אפס. בואו נריץ את
האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa על מחשב קוונטי עם Qiskit. הצעד הכי קשה הוא כנראה יצירת הפונקציה של Deutsch-Jozsa.
זו תהיה הקופסה השחורה שלנו שאנחנו שואלים כאן. הקוד הזה מייצר פונקציה אקראית של Deutsch-Jozsa שמובטח
שהיא מאוזנת או קבועה. אז אנחנו יוצרים את ה-circuit של Deutsch-Jozsa ומכניסים את הקופסה השחורה
שלנו כאן. שוב, אנחנו מריצים את ה-circuit עם sampler ואחרי שאנחנו מודדים, אנחנו מסתכלים על
הביטים שנמדדו כדי לקבוע אם הפונקציה הייתה מאוזנת או קבועה.
אם כולם אפס, היא קבועה. אבל אם יש לפחות ביט אחד של אחד במחרוזת, אז היא מאוזנת. במקרה
הזה, קיבלנו מחרוזת ביטים של 1 אחד אחד.
אז אנחנו יודעים שהפונקציה הייתה מאוזנת. אני מקווה שנתתי לכם הצצה ראשונה לאיך אלגוריתמים קוונטיים
יכולים לנצל תופעות קוונטיות מעניינות ולעתים קרובות עדינות כדי לקבל את היתרון שלהם על אלגוריתמים
קלאסיים. כנראה גם שמתם לב כמה מסובך יכול להיות לתכנן אלגוריתמים קוונטיים. אפילו הראשון
ממש דרש הרבה יצירתיות כדי להשיג ניצחון צנוע על שיטות קלאסיות. ומאז האלגוריתם הראשון,
פיזיקאים ומדעני מחשב המשיכו להמציא דרכים מדהימות להשתמש במכניקת הקוונטים
לטובתם, כולל הרחבות ויישומים נוספים של האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa. אם אתם רוצים
ללמוד על חלק מהדברים האלה, וגם לנסות את האלגוריתמים של Deutsch ו-Deutsch-Jozsa בעצמכם, לכו
למודול שמקושר בתיאור כדי להתחיל. תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה.